Game of Thrones Season 6 Episode 2 is out,
and so much huge stuff happens, let’s get
right into it.
We begin beyond the Wall with Bran and Bloodraven,
known in the books as “the three-eyed crow”,
and in the show, as the “three eyed-raven”.
Remember, Bloodraven is a sort of a mystical
mysterious tree-wizard dude, connected to
the old gods, and the children of the forest.
He trains Bran to use the powers of a greenseer,
which involves warging into animals, and having
visions of the present and past . This scene
is one of those visions, it’s of Winterfell
years ago, with a young Ned Stark, Benjen
Stark, Lyanna Stark, Rodrick Cassel, Old Nan,
and Hodor, or should we say Willas, who talks.
Hodor talks!
Which raises the question of “what happened?”
Book readers have been theorising for years
that Hodor might have had his mind broken
by seeing something cold and terrible in the
Winterfell crypts, or maybe, that during one
of Bran’s visions, he might mess with young
Hodor’s mind by trying to talk to him or
warg into him from the present.
Either way, it’s really cool that they’re
bringing this up in the show – maybe we’ll
finally find out why Hodor hodors.
It’s also awesome to see the young Stark
siblings, especially Lyanna.
She’s the one who gets caught up with Prince
Rhaegar Targaryen, which leads to Robert’s
Rebellion, the death of Lyanna and, the theories
claim, the birth of Jon Snow, which will probably
finally be revealed next episode – check
out the R+L=J video if you wanna know more.
So yeah, heaps happening up here, but Meera’s
pretty down.
To be fair, her brother died, she’s stuck
in a cave in a frozen wasteland, and all she’s
got for company is Hodor, a creepy elf-child,
and a couple of fuckin tree-wizards getting
high on greendreams . It is interesting that
this child of the forest says that Bran “isn’t
going to stay here forever”.
Lotta folks thought he would, that he’d
slowly become one with the tree, like Bloodraven,
cause really, where’s he gonna go?
He still can’t walk outside of the Matrix
of his visions.
Is Hodor gonna carry him all the way back
south, in winter, to the Wall?
Is that where Bran will fight the war for
the dawn against the white walkers, whatever
that means exactly?
And can Bloodraven really be trusted?
The plot’s progressing quickly, so we’ll
probably find out soon.
At the Wall, Alliser and his men confront
Davos and the loyal black brothers, but Wun
Wun bursts in with the wildlings and Tormund
and Edd, who take Castle Black from the Watch.
Props to this guy for thinking he could kill
a fourteen foot giant with a crossbow bolt
– better luck next time.
But yeah, like Alliser says, it really is
an historic thing to see wildlings in control
at Castle Black – in the thousands of years
of the Watch, this has, as far as we know,
never happened before.
Then down in King’s Landing, some common
bloke is talking smack about Cersei, so Robert
Strong turns up and splatters his brain on
the wall.
The Mountain has always been scary, because
he’s so huge and violent, but now that he’s
an unspeaking, unfeeling, undead monster,
the Mountain is more terrifying than ever.
But anyway King Tommen bars Cersei from going
to Myrcella’s funeral.
At the Sept we learn Tommen did this to try
to protect her, he feels guilty, feels like
he failed her – so later he goes and asks
for forgiveness, and asks for Cersei to teach
him how to be strong, which can’t possibly
go well – you can almost see some Joffrey
in Tommen’s eyes sometimes.
Back at the Sept, Jaime threatens the High
Sparrow, and the Sparrow threatens right back,
saying “together, we can overthrow an empire”.
Which sounds like a very political goal for
these religious fanatics to have, right?
Do they really just want to punish sinners
for their sins, or do they want to establish
a whole new order in capital?
There are conspiracy theories about the High
Sparrow, trying to explain who he is and what
he wants, but honestly none of it’s all
that convincing.
Hopefully we’ll find out more about the
sparrows in the episodes to come.
Over in Meereen, Tyrion, Varys, Missandei
and Grey Worm have a strategic chat.
Varys says that the slavers have taken back
Yunkai and Astapor, which could lead to a
siege of Meereen, like in the books.
Then Tyrion visits the dragons down in the
basement, and he doesn’t get roasted like
one character does in the books, in fact Tyrion
and the dragons seem to… get along.
Tyrion has this touching moment talking about
his childhood dreams of dragons, like a kid
talking about dinosaurs, and the dragons seem
to listen, and understand.
Which reminds us how little we know about
dragons.
How intelligent are they?
How loyal are they?
And just how destructive can they be?
Now that Tyrion has unchained them, we’ll
probably soon find out.
Also, this connection Tyrion seems to have
with the dragons might support the theory
that Tyrion is the son not of Tywin Lannister
but of the Mad King Aerys Targaryen.
This is a controversial theory, but it could
almost make sense.
Having Targaryen blood may allow Tyrion to
one day ride a dragon, like Daenerys does
– and Tyrion does have experience designing
unconventional saddles , which could come
in handy, so – who knows?
Then we’re in Braavos, with Arya, and “the
waif” beats her up again, asking her what
her name is, cause the Faceless Men want Arya
to let go of her identity, and become “no
one”.
The waif leaves, and Jaqen H’ghar appears
– or, more likely, “the waif” wearing
Jaqen’s face.
Remember last season someone who seemed to
be Jaqen drank poison and died, then the waif
wore Jaqen’s face, showing that any Faceless
Man can be Jaqen, because the Faceless Men
are “no one”, they have no personal identity,
but anyway Arya’s told that her time as
a beggar is done, and she’s to take on a
new identity – probably Mercy, the girl
who works in a theatre troupe.
At Winterfell, Walda gives birth to a son.
Since Ramsay is a bastard, this baby boy is
ahead of Ramsay in the line of succession,
so Ramsay stabs his father, and murders his
step-mother, and his newborn baby half-brother,
with dogs – as though Ramsay could possibly
be hated any more than he already is.
It is a little surprising that Roose goes
down so easily – cause in the books, at
least, Roose is pretty good at manipulating
and controlling his monstrous bastard, but
here, he seems to get totally caught off guard.
Regardless, Ramsay’s in charge at Winterfell
now.
We see he has the support of the Karstarks,
and also mentions the Manderleys, and the
Umbers.
The Umbers are based at Last Hearth, and that’s
where Osha takes Rickon all those seasons
ago, so maybe the Umbers will give the Boltons
Rickon as a hostage.
We also hear Ramsay’s plan to attack Castle
Black to catch Sansa and kill Jon.
He thinks it’s gonna be easy, but what he
doesn’t know is that wildlings and a giant
now guard Castle Black.
Somewhere near Winterfell, Sansa, Theon, Brienne
and Pod chill in the snow.
Brienne tells Sansa about when she saw Arya,
which is the first Sansa’s heard of her
sister since, like…
Season 1.
Brienne doesn’t mention that Arya was with
the Hound, which would be interesting for
Sansa since she’s tangled with Sandor before.
Sansa says she should have gone with Brienne
when she had the chance, last season, which
she really, really should have, and then Sansa
talks with Theon about the guilt he feels
for his crimes – he’s still very much
a broken man here.
While Brienne takes Sansa to the Wall, Theon
decides to head home – to the Iron Islands.
At the Iron Islands, we finally see Yara’s
father Balon Greyjoy, the winner of the War
of the Five Kings basically because everyone
else forgot about him.
Like Yara says, Balon really should quit while
he’s ahead, but the fool seems set on invading
the north again.
Then Balon bumps into his long lost brother
Euron Greyjoy, the Crow’s Eye, a notorious
pirate, schemer, and madman, who declares
he wants to rule, and throws Balon off a bridge
to his death below.
In the books, this may have gone differently
– it’s hinted that Euron may have hired
a Faceless Man like Jaqen or the waif to kill
Balon , which is connected to all sorts of
other crazy theories about dragon eggs and
Valyria – we’ll talk about this in an
upcoming video.
But anyway, King Balon is finally dead, which
means the Iron Islands needs a new king.
Yara is Balon’s chosen heir, which could
make her the first ever female ruler of the
ironborn.
But Yara’s other uncle Aeron tells her that
they’re gonna hold a Kingsmoot, a sort of
an election, to choose the next king.
Euron will be a candidate, he’s the crazy
big-talking outsider , while Yara is a relatively
sensible candidate who hopes to be the first
ever woman in power , and in the books there
are other candidates, including one with a
truly inspiring but possibly unrealistic utopic
vision.
Anyway, back at the Wall, Melisandre’s still
a wreck.
She’s lost her faith, and is deeply depressed.
She’s wearing furs to keep herself warm,
which is a big deal cause previously the cold
never bothered her , her faith and inner fire
kept her warm.
So she’s really in a bad place, but Davos
comes and gives her a pep talk, and Mel agrees
to try to resurrect Jon, who looks sexier
as a corpse than most men do living.
Readers have been waiting for this moment
for almost five years, and they’ve often
imagined the resurrection as something big
and dramatic and magical, involving blood
sacrifice or a burning pyre or weirwoods or
white walkers, so it’s surprising that all
it took in the end was a spongebath and a
haircut.
It’ll almost certainly be very different
in the books, but this way kinda makes sense
too – it’s very similar to how Thoros
of Myr first resurrects Beric Dondarrion – Thoros
didn’t have much faith, but he says some
prayers anyway, and Beric rises from the dead.
But the thing about Beric is that when he’s
resurrected, he loses parts of himself, bits
of his identity and memories.
George Martin, the author of the books, says
when his characters are resurrected they’re
“worse for wear”, “In some ways” “not
even the same characters anymore”, they’ve
“changed or transformed, and they’ve lost
something”.
It’s also implied that this gets worse the
longer the body’s left dead before resurrection.
So at least in the books, we should expect
Jon to be a changed man.
But the show might wanna keep things simple
and make Jon than same Snow we know and love,
either way, Jon Snow is back – this could
be a fulfilment of the prophecy of Azor Ahai,
he could be the champion of the Lord of Light,
prophesied to fight against the walkers and
the wights, he’s freed from his Watch vows
now, so if R+L=J is true, he could be crowned
as the rightful King – and at the very least
we can expect Jon to ride south against the
Boltons, perhaps to embrace his identity not
just as a Watchman, or a Snow, but as a Stark.
We’re just two episodes into Season 6 and
so much huge stuff has already happened.
Bran’s getting visions of the past, wildlings
have taken the Wall, Jaime and Sparrows are
clashing and Robert Strong is on the loose,
the dragons are free in Meereen, Arya is taking
a new role in Braavos, Ramsay takes control
at Winterfell, Brienne and Sansa head north
while Theon heads home to the Iron Islands,
where Euron arrives and the stage is set for
an election, and at Castle Black, Jon is back,
and the setup is in place for his true parentage
to be revealed.
We’re really starting to pass the books
now, which means anything could happen.
If you wanna know about Jon’s true parentage,
check out the R+L=J video, if you wanna know
about the Tyrion Targaryen theory, check that
video out, and if you want to hear the word
Hodor for two and a half minutes, watch the
Hodor video.
Special thanks to the channel Rawrist for
supporting this video.
Rawrist covers Game of Thrones and A Song
of Ice and Fire, as well as comics, sci fi,
and other pop culture, so click the link in
the description if you’d like to check her
out.
Many thanks also to all Patrons supporting
this channel, including Eli Kiani, Stacy Magerkurth,
Gary Davis, Jeffery James, Edmund Dantes,
Jake Toner, Jessica A. McWhorter, Angel Figueroa,
Niall Munnelly, Michael Cantu, Mike Bruno,
Sean Powell, Jessica O'Keefe, Randolph, and
Randall Huggins.
Thanks for watching, please like and subscribe
– see ya next week.